in this video we'll talk about the
rizazurin assay which is one of the cell
viability assay
this resulting assay is used to detect
whether the cells are viable or dead
this kind of assays are widely used to
investigate cell responses towards a
given agent drug and to understand the
effect of cytotoxicity or kind of like
harmful effect of a drug
so question is how does this assay work
if a cell is viable its mitochondria
would be functional it mitochondria
would produce nadh ATP and fadh
so in this particular essay a die is
added in a Cell culture and this dye is
resoline and it is blue in color which
is non-fluorescent now with the help of
mitochondrial dehydrogenase enzyme and
nadh produced from the citric acid cycle
this particular dye would be reduced
into a pink or highly fluorescence form
of that type
this fluorescence can be detected using
a proper detector and if the
fluorescence is detected that means the
cells are viable and mitochondria is
functioning that's why nadh or
dehydrogenase enzymes are
properly able to convert it into a
fluorescent form
out keep key points regarding this assay
it's a fluorescence-based assay for
assessing cell viability the amount of
risophene which is the pink tie can be
monitored by measuring the fluorescence
and
in this case depending on the cell type
one can use like as few as 40 cells to
do this assay reproducibly that means
it's very sensitive
now when it comes to the advantage of
Reason assay it is highly sensitive
then it is a very simple asset to
perform it's not complicated doesn't
require very high profile uh instruments
now overall the kinetics of this
reaction can be monitored so a Time
Point based analysis can be done it is
safe non-toxic non-radioactive
non-carcinogenic so from all aspect it's
a very nice assay and it can be it is
quite versatile that means it can be
used on different different cell types
including mammalian cells bacteria
protozoa yeast fungi literally every
eukaryotic cell or prokaryotic cell
so in order to perform this assay you
have to have a cell culture Hood so in
the cell culture Hood you have to first
seed your cells that you want to assess
maybe would have your treatment
condition or it would have your control
condition
then as a step two you have to add 10
microliters of registering in the
solution
and then
this particular plate has to be
incubated at 37 degree Centigrade for
about four hours
then the fluorescence would possibly be
developed and it should be monitored
using a Plate Reader so the excitation
is some around like 570 and the emission
is some around 590.
so with that one can calculate the
viability of the cells
now let us try to understand a real life
scenario let's say you have a tumor
sample and you have a particular drug
and you think that by putting this drug
the tumor would be eliminated so there
would be lot of cell death and in order
to understand
the cell viability you can possibly
perform this particular assay so here is
your experimental setup you have a
control cell cells and you have
treatment cells where you have added the
newly synthesized chemical compound and
then you would perform the risazurin
assay so if the cells are viable then it
would show high fluorescence if the
cells are not so viable it would show
low fluorescence and that can be
Quantified using the Plate Reader and
the graph can be generated in this case
the graph shows that after treatment
viability has decreased
is very useful to detect cell valid cell
viability after any kind of
exposure to chemicals I hope this was
useful if you like this video give it a
thumbs up don't forget to follow us on
Facebook or Instagram you can get more
notes and flashcards in our Facebook
anyway you can support our Channel using
super thanks after clicking on super
thanks you can pay via paytm Paypal UPI
alternatively you can support us on
patreon
do follow us on social media all the
links are provided in the description
see you in the next video
foreign